let's turn to some lighter news the end
of the world the news is constantly full
of potential causes whether it's nuclear
Armageddon or environmental destruction
I told you that bear is the new face of
Earth Day but but as we learned earlier
this year one news network has actually
planned what they'll show during
humanity's final moments if this is ever
on CNN it means the world is coming to
an end
it's called Turner doomsday video
something Ted Turner actually produced
in the early days of CNN to air on
doomsday when the world's ending the
video restriction even says quote hold
for release till end of the world
confirmed
that's great CNN so you're gonna wait
till the end of the worlds to actually
confirm something I'm intrigued by this
I'm intrigued by the idea so so tell me
what is the last thing CNN wants all of
us to see
[Music]
that's it a bands playing a slow dirge
well to be fair when the world ends it
would be comforting to look at any
marching band and think well at least
they'll all die too just as I know if
the music they were playing rings a bell
that there might be a reason for that in
the video the Armed Forces marching
bands play nearer my God to thee to him
that as legend has it was played as the
Titanic sank whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
that was not the music that played when
the Titanic sank this was
[Music]
[Applause]
yes the last thing goes drowning people
heard was some sort of french-canadian
space mermaids that's a fact
that's a history fact look if humanity's
time on earth is going to end this
cannot be the last thing we all see
because a doomsday video shouldn't just
be sad it should be celebratory so with
that in mind we've produced a new video
for the end of the world for CNN and
anyone else to use
please enjoy hello I'm Michael Sheen and
I'm afraid if you're watching this the
end times are upon us whether because of
war disease or a genetically modified
dinosaur our world is now only moments
away from total annihilation
so let's take these last few moments to
celebrate the greatest things about
humanity's time on earth we had a good
run didn't we we harnessed fire invented
languages and engineered transparent
underwater tunnels simply because we
felt like looking at shark tunnels we
were the first species to evolve to walk
on two legs and then invented a way not
to but for half humanity's greatest
achievement of all was our total
domination of every other species nice
try lions unless of course we're all
dying because lions evolved and
conquered the human race in which case
well played
now let's admit humanity sometimes
failed to live up to our potential as
evidenced by our Bluebird tragically it
seems our time together as a species is
drawing short and life on Earth is about
to end
so before we all embrace whatever awaits
us I have something important to show
it's a model of an Old West saloon
filled with cat bartenders and cat
cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]
cats in conclusion don't be sad over
what we're losing
instead think fondly of what we have so
let's give thanks to peanut butter two
water slides to the night sky to the
Beatles and the pyramids to that YouTube
video of Kelsey Grammer falling off the
stage you and we did things that feel
thought possible
we mastered the art of the yo-yo and had
a cereal that was nothing but cookies
we invented the automobile and then
invented an automobile that could drive
over 20 other orders we made backpacks
that look like animals and then have
those same animals wear them he set
magnificently pointless world records we
mastered relative time and hammertime we
developed string theory and string
cheese and you know what else we went to
the moon so now before we're all
vaporized or whatever awaits us I think
it's fitting that the last thing we all
see is this sick basketball shot
[Music]
we did this is Martin Sheen over in
you